the fact that this national dialogue is
taking place at all for some
Cameroonians represents progress I've
involved hundreds of thousands of people
displaced by the current crisis they
what they want to look forward to is how
quickly the government can step in to
alleviate their sufferings people who've
been displaced by this crisis over the
last two years in the two regions of
Northwest and southwest of Cameroon
displaced for the second time informants
Florence Shea and her family have found
shelter with this church the mother of
six fled fighting between separatists
and government forces in income be a
husband was killed and our home was
burned when she arrived in the capital
she hoped life would get better she was
wrong we are treated like animals we are
not treated like human beings we have
been these places here internally
displaced people you see people living
in the houses where there is no roof I
had those things in the Norden I never
know it would come to me she says there
is a lot of distrust among the people
underlining a growing divide between the
English and French speaking peoples of
Cameroon a country considered more
stable the neighboring states only eight
years ago since then more than half a
million people have been displaced by
the separatist violence another forty to
fifty thousand have crossed the border
into Nigeria as refugees Boko Haram
attacks in the north and a fallout from
the last national elections have added
to a long list of problems despite deep
divisions religion is a common threat
binding Cameroonians of different faiths
and that is not lost on the government
its officials are attending this
interfaith service to drum up support
for the national dialogue it would
replace violence
what understanding it will replace all
upheavals with a smooth functioning of
the state and
absent from the dialog you don't want to
participate in nation-building so it's
important that you should commence it
with no preconditions and this goes but
already there are concerns as to how
much it can achieve many secessionist
won't be here so they sent in a former
United States diplomat to represent them
president for BIA wants to use the
discussions to convince them to lay down
their arms and to start a healing
process for camera more than four
hundred delegates will be attending the
talks over the course of five days
they'll attempt to draw national
consensus to break cameras political
stalemate but it's hard to say for now
if the outcome will be acceptable to all
parties well many expect to see that the
government at some stage after this
conference will devolve certain powers
to regional governments strengthen their
ability to deliver goods and services to
other regions
where these cameras have been coming
from like more funding for education
health and infrastructure in those
regions which will according to the
government help to alleviate some of the
sufferings being experienced in some of
these regions